- Thank you all for coming to
Quantum Computing with Amazon Bracket:
From Exploration to Enterprise.
My name is Eric Kessler.
I'm the general manager of Amazon Bracket,
our quantum computing service by AWS,
so you're gonna learn more about that,
but I'm very excited to be joined today
also by Michael Brett.
He's the head of go-to-market
for quantum computing at AWS,
and yeah, we're gonna give you
a little bit of an overview,
what we have been up to at AWS,
how we see the industry evolve,
and what you can do today
already with this technology.
To give you a little bit, an overview,
what to expect today, I'm
gonna give you a little bit
of an introduction of
what is quantum computing
and where are we today.
Then we're gonna go into
a bit of an overview
of what we're doing at
AWS before we dive into
hybrid quantum classical workloads
and how we're supporting these type of
cutting-edge workloads at AWS.
And finally, we're
looking at one particular
customer case study, which
was about drug design
with AstraZeneca.
And finally, we're gonna show you
how you can get started
with quantum computing.
But I wanted to get out of the gate here
with addressing a very
common misconception
about quantum computing.
Namely, a quantum computer
is not a classical computer
that just runs a little bit faster.
As a matter of fact, quantum computers
are actually very slow
compared to the clock cycles
from classical computers.
Instead, a quantum computer
can run a richer class
of algorithms compared
to classical computers.
And you may ask, why do we need
a richer class of algorithms?
We have our classical algorithms
and they work just fine.
Well, it turns out there are
certain types of applications
where all the algorithms that we know
require an exponential overhead
as the problem gets bigger and bigger,
exponentially, the time that it needs,
the memory that it needs,
other resources that it needs.
And one of the prototypical
problems of that kind
is to simulate quantum systems themselves.
So this is kind of the
home turf applications
of quantum computers.
Because when we just look at the system,
say particles, electrons, that behave,
that interact with each other,
behave quantum mechanically,
if we want to simulate them
with a classical computer,
already 50 of those particles require
supercomputing scale classical computing.
And because it is exponential,
if we go from 50 to 100 particles,
it becomes completely out of reach
for any computer today
and in the future, right?
And of course, this idea
is almost the founding idea
of quantum computing and
goes back a long time now
from 1981 by Richard Feynman
in this very famous quote
where he said, "Nature isn't classical
"and if you want to make
a simulation of nature,
"then you better make
it quantum mechanical."
And by golly, it's a wonderful problem
because it doesn't look so easy.
And that's true, it's
actually a very hard problem
to build a quantum computer.
And the technology is still early,
but we're seeing a lot
of improvements, right?
So as the take home message,
quantum computers can solve some problems
with exponentially fewer
gates or fewer operations
than classical computers
because they use different
types of algorithms.
So to put it in a very provocatively,
it's not a two X speed up,
but a two to the power
of X speed up, right?
And because it's exponential,
that's the difference between
something that's possible
and something that's
not possible to compute.
So from that very brief introductions,
there are actually some
very profound learnings
or lessons we can take, right?
Because quantum computers are
not just a classic computer
that runs faster, it
means also that quantum
will not replace classical
computers, right?
If you have a classical algorithm
that does not scale exponentially,
that works well for the
problem that you have,
there's no argument why
you would replace it
with a quantum computer because
they're generally slower,
they're generally more expensive.
The second point is that many use cases
of quantum computers are
hidden by definition.
And what do I mean with this, right?
If you look around at your company
and think about what are the applications
that a quantum computer could be used for,
chances are there are some
applications you don't see
because they are not possible to solve
with classical computers today, right?
Because by definition, we
wanna apply quantum computing
to problems that are hard
for classical computers.
And the final one is,
because we're talking about
a new class of algorithms,
these applications are not
just lift and shift, right?
When we have a quantum computer
at some point in the future
that can address
industry-relevant problems,
we cannot just take what we were running
on a classical computer before
and move it over to a quantum
computer and it will work.
These are completely new algorithms,
completely new primitives,
and it requires a lot of
talent and skills and IP
to develop these kind of algorithms.
And we're very excited
about these algorithms
because applications are applicable
to a wide field of verticals, right?
So we already talked about
the home turf kind of problems
on the left-hand side,
like problems where we
try to describe nature
for all intents and purposes
in physics and chemistry,
simulating molecules and
reactions, et cetera,
developing new materials
and material science.
But maybe very surprisingly,
it doesn't stop there, right?
Quantum computers are not
only exponentially faster
for these type of problems,
for some of these problems,
but there are also certain problems
that are inherently classical,
where it has been shown
that quantum computers
do provide an advantage.
Well, maybe the most famous
one is in cryptography, right,
where the Shor's algorithm showed
that you can factor large
numbers exponentially faster
than with a classical computer, right?
There's this relevance
for RSA and encryption
and so on and so forth, but
then there are also problems
in the space of optimization,
and machine learning is a
little bit more nuanced here,
and a lot of research is
being done in those topics.
Well, all of this is to say that we at AWS
really think quantum computing
is a foundational compute technology,
and like with other compute technologies,
we want to bring these
capabilities to our customers,
and in the fullness of time,
make them part of our offering,
our compute fabric at AWS, right?
So in some sense,
our job at AWS is to make
quantum computing boring, right?
When you look at the accelerated
compute portfolio at AWS,
we have already different
types of accelerators,
from GPUs to AI and ML accelerators,
ASICs and FPGAs, and so on and so forth,
from different providers,
and in the fullness of time,
I think quantum is just
another type of accelerator.
But of course, it's a long
journey to that place,
and to throw a little bit of cold water,
I want to really stress that
the technology is early,
and today there is no quantum computer
that can solve any
industry-relevant problem
faster, cheaper, or more accurately
than the best classical alternative.
So then, what are customers
using quantum computers
for today, right?
Well, like any other technology,
quantum computing will not start
with the broad-scale adoption,
but it will start from niche applications
and gradually grow from there,
and I like to make the
analogy with GPUs, right?
GPUs started for a very
niche application space
of graphics processing, until,
researchers in academia realized
it can be used for
mathematical calculations,
big matrix multiplications, and so on,
until they finally got
the broad-scale adoptions
through AI and machine learning.
And in the same way,
quantum computers today,
what most of our customers do,
is using quantum computers
to study quantum computing,
right?
From researching the devices,
the sources of noise,
developing error mitigation protocols,
to researching these
novel types of algorithms,
trying to understand how they converge,
how they are impacted by this noise,
so trying to close the gap
between what the hardware
brings from the bottom
and what applications come from the top.
But of course, ultimately,
we don't wanna just
study the hammer, right?
We want to actually use the hammer, right?
Using quantum computers as a tool
to solve problems in other domains.
And the first areas where we will solve
different kind of problems
will be in the space of
scientific applications, right?
To drive new scientific
discovery in high-energy physics,
in material science, in
quantum materials, and so on,
before we go into this final step
into broadly industry-relevant problems
with broad-scale adoption.
And we are at a very exciting
time of the industry,
I think, right?
We are just at that cusp of going over
from studying the hammer
to using, actually, the hammer, right?
And against that backdrop,
I wanted to introduce you
to what we're doing at AWS
to help accelerate that technology
to help make that promise of
quantum computing a reality.
So in a nutshell, our
quantum technologies at AWS,
we have four pillars.
This is Amazon Bracket, our
quantum computing service.
You're gonna hear about that more.
We have the Amazon Advanced Solutions Lab.
This is a professional services team
that focuses on quantum computing
and related classical technologies.
And then we have the AWS
Center for Quantum Computing.
It's a research facility
where we're developing our
own quantum computing hardware
and quantum error correction technologies.
And finally, we have our
post-quantum cryptography team
and quantum networking team
that's part of AWS Core Networking.
So let's start with a brief overview.
So the AWS Center for Quantum Computing,
already mentioned, is
an AWS research center
that's located at Caltech.
We are building our own quantum
computing hardware there
with a quantum error
correction first approach.
So we really want to address
that next level of scaling
that is required to take the technology
from studying the hammer
to using the hammer.
We're building on a technology
that is dubbed Cat Qubits,
which combines superconducting
qubits with resonators,
microwave resonators, to
suppress certain types of noise.
And I'll talk a little bit more
about that on the next slide.
As a matter of fact, just
beginning of the year,
we showed and published results
from our first prototype
that's called Ocelot.
There's a picture of the chip here.
And we were able to show that
through that architecture,
this Cat-Qubit architecture,
we are able to suppress
a certain type of noise
to a degree where the resources required
to implement error correction
on this architecture
is 10 times lower than in
the traditional approach.
So we're very excited about these results.
But of course, our approach
is only one of many, right?
There are many other promising directions
from building quantum computers with ions
that are trapped,
building quantum computers
with neutral Rydberg atoms
or photons and many others.
And at the same time, we
believe that we need to bring
this technology in the
hands of our customers
so that they can experiment
with this technology,
start developing algorithms,
and start developing the IP around
how we can bring the new applications
and the resource requirements
of them further down.
And that was the reason for us
why we launched Amazon Bracket
in 2020 at this point, right?
We wanted to democratize
quantum computing,
bring different types of quantum computers
in the hands of our customers
so that they can learn, experiment,
but also do research into applications
and envision how quantum
computers will be used
in the context of AWS,
in the context of existing HPC pipelines.
And today, we provide access to
third-party quantum computers
and in the future also, of course,
our own AWS-built quantum
computers in the fullness of time,
all in one consistent experience.
The quantum computers that
we have available today
is from five different providers.
That is two ion trap providers,
IonQ and Alpine Quantum Technology, AQT.
We have two providers that are building
superconducting QPUs with Rigetti and IQM.
And finally, we have a provider
that is building Rydberg-based
quantum computers from QuEra.
So we wanna give customers that choice
and the ability to contrast
and compare the different approaches.
Each of them have different
pros, different cons.
It is not clear that this
is a winner-take-all market
by any means, right?
There is a lot of different
potential applications
for each of these technologies
because they have all very
different characteristics
and different programming paradigms.
And we wanna give customers
that visibility into the technology.
So then, let's take a
look at a 20,000-foot view
to Amazon Bracket.
And we think about Bracket
in kind of three different layers, right?
Like at the bottom, you
have the infrastructure
and the access modes, right?
So we are providing access to QPUs,
to quantum circuit simulators,
as well as to the classical compute
that is used with quantum
computers in tandem.
We're gonna hear about
that more from Michael.
And we can access these quantum computers
in different access mode.
For example, on-demand,
just pay-as-you-go as you used from AWS.
You can also make reservations
where you get dedicated
time on a particular device
where only you can access it
at the time that suits you.
In the middle part of the stack,
we're providing the interfaces
and capabilities, right?
From Jupyter IDEs to
programming tools and compilers
and a feature for executing
quantum hybrid algorithms
with hybrid jobs.
And then finally, at the top of the layer,
we want to bring different type
of tooling to our customers
that they are used to
and want to use, right?
We are supporting all of the major
quantum computing frameworks
from IBM's Qiskit to Penny Lane
and NVIDIA's CUDA Quantum, CUDA Q,
as well as a whole list
of software tooling
and programming frameworks
from our partners.
Many of them are here at re:Invent today
and giving their presentations.
I encourage everybody to check that out.
But essentially, we're realizing
we can't build it all on our own.
And we want to make sure
that anything runs on bracket
and we bring the tooling to our customers
that they want to use.
And throughout that stack,
we are trying constantly
to improve the performance,
make the user experience better,
get more throughput performance
and quality performance
out of these early stage devices.
And there's a lot we could talk about
with the different capabilities.
I picked out a feature that
we just recently launched.
This is Amazon Bracket Program Sets.
So the idea here is that
the way you interact
with a quantum computer
is not that you send a single program
and you get it back and you analyze it.
In reality, a very common workload pattern
is that you send multiple
of these programs
that either are related to each
other, they can be the same,
they can be somehow connected
or also completely independent.
And for each and every
program that you send,
you need to compile it, you
need to have the I/O overhead
of bringing it down to the
control system of the QPU,
load it onto the FPGA
and so on and so forth.
So there is overhead
in each of those steps.
And with Program Sets,
we're allowing customers,
we're enabling customers
to submit multiple quantum programs,
a whole series of quantum programs
in a single payload
with a single API call,
which allows us to optimize that payload,
compile it and gain efficiencies
through compilations
and I/O process, bringing
multiple programs
at the same time onto the FPGA.
And for certain types of workloads,
we're seeing up to 24x
speedups with this feature.
So with that, I wanna come back
to this kind of inverted
pyramid of use cases.
And as we discussed before,
we think that the first use cases
will be in the scientific domain
before we go into broad industry adoption.
And I don't wanna downplay
this as a mere stepping stone
because I think it's a very
profound fact, actually,
that quantum computers will change the way
that we understand nature,
that we can understand how nature behaves
at the microscopic level.
And in fact, a recent study from NERSC,
this is a supercomputing facility
from the Department of Energy,
found that at least 50% of
their production workload
has the potential to be
exponentially accelerated
by quantum computers.
So there's a tremendous opportunity
to accelerate research and scientific work
through quantum computing directly.
And many countries and
governments around the world
are realizing this opportunity.
So this was one study from NERSC.
Other studies, for example, from LANL
find numbers between 30 and 50%.
But countries around the world realizing
that this is an opportunity
to accelerate scientific breakthroughs
and have founded national
quantum initiatives
to find those first use cases
and then also use it as a stepping stone
for further industry adoptions.
And a number of those
government initiatives,
national initiatives,
they're building with
Amazon Bracket, right?
Because the first thing
that they want to have
is to give access to quantum computers
to their local research communities.
With Amazon Bracket, they
get access to HPC resources
and quantum computers on demand.
We build scalable and
secure research environments
as well as a tailored
administrative and budget controls
to run large-scale research
organizations in the cloud.
For example, we're working
with the NQCH in Singapore,
with the NQCC in the
UK, QCloud in Ireland,
and POSI in Australia.
As a matter of fact, we just launched,
POSI just launched the quantum hub portal
which provides researchers
access to quantum computing
and classical computing
resources through AWS
with tailored administrative controls.
And they're now starting
to run the Zettonics QPilot
where they will allocate
quantum computing resources
for local researchers to drive
that innovation flywheel.
And we're super excited
about initiatives like this
because we think there's a
lot of research to be done
and by having access to
real quantum computers,
that research can accelerate.
So, but of course, we are all very excited
about bringing that technology
also out of academia
into broad industry adoption
and Michael is gonna tell
us more about that idea
and how we're going to drive
our customer engagement
in this field.
Take it away, Michael.
- Thank you.
Well, thanks very much, Eric.
Wonderful introduction
to Bracket as a service.
(audience applauds)
So Eric and I work very closely together.
He builds and operates
the Bracket service.
He makes it available to our customers
so that he can use it
through the AWS console.
It's a service that's available
in the cloud for you today.
You can access quantum computers
just in the way that you would
any other service on AWS.
So if you enjoy using EC2,
you're gonna love using Bracket
'cause it's just another service
but we've got quantum computers on there.
My job is to talk to
our enterprise customers
about where quantum computing is headed
and how they will be able to
make use of this in the future,
the kind of workloads that
they'll be interested in,
the thinking that they
need to go through now
to prepare their strategies
for quantum computing in the future.
Most of our customers today
on Bracket are researchers,
as Eric mentioned.
They're national labs, they're hubs,
they are individual
researchers at universities.
Most of them are doing science.
So they come to AWS to
use the infrastructure
that we've got available
to do good science.
So they're collecting data,
they're doing physics research,
they're doing computer science research,
they're doing application and
benchmarking style research.
But as we build up this stack,
we move from the science
to looking more at
solving industrial scientific use cases.
So we'll give an example in a
moment about drug discovery,
but also think about materials design,
think about production opportunities.
But at the big scale and
where we wanna get to
is how do we use quantum computers
for large-scale enterprise problems
in exactly the same way that we use
high-performance compute
classically today at AWS.
So some companies are
really starting to invest
in this ahead of the curve.
There are a few leaders out there
that are really investing
in quantum computing
in understanding those use cases
and where the potential might be.
One of those companies is JPMorgan Chase.
We actually have another
breakout session tomorrow,
which I encourage you to
come to, with JPMorgan Chase,
where we will go through
exactly how we operate
the end-to-end application
study and benchmarking work
that we've been doing with
them for the past year.
But their motivation is really clear.
Marco Pistoia, who until very recently
led the quantum computing
program at JPMorgan.
He's since gone on to a
wonderful new opportunity
at a quantum computing hardware company.
But he said, "If a company
doesn't do anything
"about the market right now,
"when quantum advantage becomes
real, it might be too late."
And this is really important.
This is a fast-moving technology.
This is not just a lift and shift
from an existing HPC workload
to a quantum compute workload.
These are complex algorithms.
They're complex problems.
They take some thinking to work through
to design new approaches
to running quantum classical hybrid work,
to running workflows together.
And so the leading organizations
in enterprise adoption of quantum compute
are really thinking about this now
in anticipation of that
future potential advantage.
So here's the journey that we
go through with them on it.
We look at, through a discovery
process around use cases,
helping them identify
the kinds of workloads
that are well-suited
to a quantum computer.
We then research and benchmark with them
the quantum computing algorithms.
So we compare quantum on quantum.
How does one quantum
computing hardware system
compare to another quantum
computing hardware system?
We also compare quantum
and classical together.
So how does the best
available classical approach
to that problem match
with the quantum computing
approach to that?
And then look at the hybrid opportunities.
What if we combine
different things together
and orchestrate across
multiple different platforms
on AWS to explore this space?
And that's what pushing the
boundaries is all about.
How do we unlock the potential
of end-to-end compute,
so using a quantum computer
to make classical computers go faster?
And then that will lay
the groundwork for us
for production applications in the future.
So bringing all this together,
we want our customers to be prepared
so that as soon as Amazon
Bracket gets bigger
and we've got more capacity
and we're scaling up
across multiple regions,
you are ready with your workloads
to jump straight into that.
So last year at reInvent,
we launched a program
called Quantum Embark.
Quantum Embark is our sort of entry point
for any enterprise customers
to just get started
with quantum computing.
So if you're not quite sure what to do,
you know you should do something,
but you're not sure what
that something should be,
this is the program for you.
So it is a 12-week,
fixed-price, fixed-scope program
to just get started in quantum computing
and work with our teams to
work through that process
that I just described on the last slide.
So the use case discovery,
do some training and enablement together,
and then deep dive on
one particular problem.
So let's pick one problem
from your organization
and solve it together.
Go through the process
to write out the quantum
computing algorithms,
compare it to the classical algorithms,
fit it onto a quantum computer on Bracket,
benchmark it quantum to
classical and quantum to quantum.
That process takes about 12 weeks.
We work as a joint team together,
so some of our solution architects
and applied science specialists
around quantum computing,
some of your team as well,
and we bring that together.
The whole idea is that
we're able to give you
and your executive teams
actionable outcomes
without the hype.
There's a lot of hype and excitement,
and for good reason,
around quantum computing,
but how do we make it real for
your particular organization
and so the Quantum Embark
program is all about that,
giving you some actionable outcomes
so that you can understand
if and when quantum computing
is gonna have an impact on your business,
and then you can start to inform
the rest of the stakeholders
across your company
about where that's headed.
A little bit deeper, we've got a team
called the Advanced Solutions Lab.
This is our professional services team
that engages directly with customers
to do long-term R&D engagements
around quantum computing.
Our colleague Martin Schutz
from the Advanced Solutions Lab
will be on stage tomorrow
at the breakout session
I was mentioning with JP Morgan Chase
to talk about exactly this.
They had a three-year program of effort
looking at multiple problems
across quantum computing
at every level, so from optimization
of how to use particular devices
to compilation strategies
to application benchmarking.
This is a deep research team.
This team will design
a custom R&D engagement
for your particular needs.
They'll work with you to develop
and explore novel quantum
computing algorithms.
We'll look at opportunities to
deliver business value today
on classical compute hardware,
but most importantly, generate
that intellectual property
so that you've got the know-how and the IP
so that you can take
advantage of quantum computing
as it matures over time.
Practically now, let's take a look at
what does quantum computing mean
for our entire accelerated
compute portfolio.
So if you are a user of AWS's
high-performance compute services,
where does quantum computing fit
into that overall landscape?
And the good news is that in some ways,
bracket and quantum computing
is just another instance
of compute on AWS.
It's just another type
of accelerated computing.
So we have CPUs, GPUs,
other accelerated processes
like Trainium and Inferentia.
Well, quantum computing is
just one more type of computer
in that overall portfolio.
And so we've been doing
a lot of work this year
to integrate bracket as
another sort of instance type
within the high-performance
compute services of AWS.
So you might be familiar with
the Parallel Compute Service,
with AWS Batch, with Parallel Cluster.
This is for classical HPC.
So if you're the Formula
One, if you're Ferrari,
and you need to do
computational fluid dynamics,
those are the services that you're using
to do those large industrial-scale
heavy compute workloads on AWS.
They don't go directly to
EC2 to spin up instances.
They use these orchestration tools
to do those large-scale problems.
And so we're looking at
how do we integrate bracket
directly into that?
You should be able to go straight
to the high-performance compute services
and spin up accelerated compute instances
of multiple different types
that include quantum computing
and orchestrate across that entire
end-to-end workflow over time.
So we've been doing a lot of work
to integrate that into the systems,
and the example that I'm
gonna show you in a second
is based on exactly that framework.
So think about AWS as
the core infrastructure.
We've got compute and
networking and storage.
Bracket is just another
form of compute on there.
Different abilities to consume
that compute over time.
So on our classical infrastructure,
we've got on-demand,
we've got capacity blocks,
we do spot, reserve instances.
We're building out exactly the same
for bracket over time as well.
So right now, you can
log into the console,
you can access bracket on-demand,
you only pay for what you use,
no upfront commitment to
use a quantum computer,
or you can reserve a
capacity block next Tuesday
at 3 p.m. to do your
particular workload as well.
So we really are thinking
about quantum computing
as just another computer
within the framework
that you're already used to running
large-scale workloads on AWS.
So let's take a look at what a large-scale
end-to-end industrial
strength workflow looks like.
So this is a very typical kind of workflow
for one of our high-performance
compute customers.
They might be doing drug discovery,
computational fluid dynamics,
some kind of engineering analysis,
circuit layout, something like that.
And there'll be some user
action process right at the top
that will flow down to an execution plan,
there'll be some I/O on there,
there'll be an orchestration layer
handling different types of compute,
but all of this numerical
heavy lifting that's going on.
That could be a couple of hours of work,
couple of weeks of work,
couple of months of work that's going on.
We see everything in between.
And the idea of quantum computing is,
well, what if we could interleave
some parts of that overall workflow
that are well-suited to a quantum computer
so we're still doing quantum
and classical together,
but in a hybrid modality?
Can we get an end-to-end speedup?
Can we reduce the entire
operational end-to-end workflow
of a large-scale
high-performance compute workload
and get a faster result for our customers
and hopefully a lower cost
result for our customers as well?
So we're at the very early stages
of putting this into practice.
And we've got a great example
with our customer AstraZeneca
that we worked with earlier this year
to explore exactly this kind of problem.
And so this was a joint
program that we did together
between AstraZeneca, IonQ,
the quantum computing hardware
company that's on bracket,
NVIDIA, and AWS.
So it was the four
companies working together,
looking at the algorithm problems,
the orchestration problems,
how we bring that back together
as an end-to-end workflow
and to see what kind of
result we could get there.
And so the particular problem
that we were looking at
was this chemistry problem
called transition metal catalysis.
And it underpins so much of what happens
in modern drug design.
This is part of the everyday workflow
that every drug company
in the world goes through.
And it's a really tough
computational problem to solve.
It is very difficult
for a classical computer
to simulate this because as the complexity
of these molecules grows,
the amount of connections between them
also increases exponentially
and it becomes harder and
harder to simulate that.
But if we could simulate
these accurately and early,
then we could identify
new synthesis routes
before going to the wet lab,
before doing that work,
mixing chemicals together
to see what would actually happen.
And so the particular chemistry problem
that we looked at here
was something called
the oxidative addition and
Suzuki-Miyaura coupling,
the nickel catalyst, really
rolls off the tongue.
But the idea here is that
we're looking at a catalytic process.
So we're going from that
B state up to the BC state
and then down to the C.
And so that's an energy barrier
that we need to get over.
So we're modeling out what
happens in the real world
in real chemistry, quantum
mechanical process,
going over this energy barrier
through a catalytic state.
And that determines whether
the height of that barrier
determines whether this
reaction is going to run at all.
So if it's too high, if
it's too much of a barrier,
when we go into the wet lab,
that's not going to come together
as the molecule that we want.
So we wanna understand
before we go to the lab,
the height of that barrier
and what the end state is going to be.
Solving that problem is
really, really tough.
This is the classical workflow for it.
So we start with
calculating an active space
and then there's something
called the trial wave function,
which is one of the hardest
parts of this overall state.
This is where the quantum bonds
are being understood by the computers.
And then we hand it off
to classical systems
to run some Monte Carlo analysis
and find the overall energy
state at the end of that.
But it turns out that we can replace
one part of this workflow
with a quantum computing
algorithm instead.
And so working together,
AstraZeneca, NVIDIA, IonQ and AWS,
we said, what if we went
classical, quantum, classical?
We put a whole bunch of, we
adapt the classical algorithm
to better suit a quantum computer
and then we also adapt
the classical workload
that happens afterwards.
Can we get a better result
from that over time?
So we took a look at adapting
that trial wave state function preparation
on the IonQ Forte-1 machine.
At the time that we ran this,
this was the latest device
that we had on bracket.
And we ran what we think
was the largest scale
quantum compute workload
that's ever been run
on these systems.
And so it was fitting those
molecules that we saw before
through that energy state transition
onto the quantum computer
and doing a whole bunch
of sampling around that.
We then moved those results over
to classical post-processing
using AWS Parallel Cluster,
one of our high-performance
compute services.
And we ran the Monte Carlo simulations
to find the final energy state there.
We used a lot of compute to do this.
We used 40 P5 EN instances.
Those are the H100 instances from NVIDIA
for a couple of days
running compute on here.
So it was a big workload.
The end-to-end state here,
we think, is the largest
end-to-end workload
that's ever been run quantum
and classical together.
And the results are
really, really promising.
What this chart is showing,
on the x-axis is the system size,
essentially the size of the molecules,
the size of the atoms
that we're looking at.
So bigger and bigger molecules
as we go out to the right-hand side.
And on the y-axis is the runtime
in seconds on a log scale.
So more processing time to get there.
The dashed lines that you see
were the previous best
available classical results
that we had from this.
So as these molecules got bigger,
the previous best classical systems
were in those dashed lines there.
The solid line is what we're
able to produce classically
on this hybrid workflow.
So the particular solid dot
that's in the middle there
is this particular result,
so right in the middle.
So that gap between the
solid dot on the solid line
and the lowest level of the dashed line,
that is the performance increase
that we're able to get
between these two workloads.
And that is a 656 times speedup
over that part of the processing cycle
that we went through there.
So a really significant result.
Now, this isn't something that
we could put in production.
When we had to play a lot
of tricks on our system
to make this work, we had to learn a lot
about the orchestration of
running a hybrid workload on AWS.
And it took a lot of compute to do this.
So we can't run this in
production every day.
Also, we weren't looking
at the cost around it.
But it gives us a lot of confidence
that as we're building out these systems,
as we get bigger and bigger,
as we're able to do more and more
sophisticated orchestration
across high-performance compute,
that as these molecules get bigger,
we're going to see a
huge performance increase
that we're gonna be able to
deliver to customers there.
So as we extrapolate out
to molecules like FeMoCo
that are really important to problems
in industrial processing
and nitrogen fixation,
and hopefully, eventually,
things like fertilizer production,
that we're going to be
able to model these systems
in a really interesting way.
So I just wanna remind
everyone of something
that Eric said right at the
top of the presentation,
that no quantum computer today
can solve an industry-relevant problem
faster, cheaper, or more accurately
than the best available
classical alternative.
That is still true.
The example that I showed you before
does not yet meet these criteria.
But it's a stepping stone to that.
We can really see and
have a lot of confidence
around where this is headed.
As these computers get bigger,
as they get more capable,
we are gonna be able to
tick off these things,
to be able to go faster,
to be able to go cheaper,
to be able to do things more accurately
than the best available
classical alternative,
and be able to do it in
production over time as well.
So what can you do today?
How do you take action around this?
Well, this is what the
leading companies are doing.
They're generating IP.
They're generating the algorithms
that will run on these quantum computers.
They're generating the know-how
about how to operate it in the cloud.
And so you can do that too.
You can get engaged with us
or with our partner network
and explore what the
intellectual property portfolio
looks like that will have an impact
on your compute solutions.
You can engage the supply chain.
You're understanding
the quantum computing hardware companies,
understanding the software libraries,
the open source community, the
partners that are out there,
the university researchers
that are engaged in this.
You're having a deep understanding
of where your compute is gonna come from,
where your algorithms are gonna come from,
where your software
library is gonna come from.
It's an important part of the puzzle.
And then finally, build a workforce.
Have a few people within your organization
who can understand this technology,
who can make sense of it for
your particular organization,
who can start to read the news
and be able to process it in
a way that's relevant to you
and be able to react quickly
as computers get more and
more capable over time.
And so we're here to help you do that.
We've got a lot of options available
for you to engage with us
at AWS on quantum compute.
In the middle is Bracket.
This is an operational service
in general availability on AWS today.
We've been running this for five years.
You can access quantum computers
in the cloud this afternoon if you'd like.
We actually have a series
of workshops this week
so you can get hands-on
with quantum computing
in one of our workshops through
the rest of these sessions.
Couple of other options.
We've got a digital badge
available on AWS Skill Builder.
You can work through a course,
get a digital badge through that.
Quantum Embark we talked about before
for enterprise customers to
engage in quantum computing.
The Advanced Solutions Lab if
you wanna do a deeper project.
And then Amazon Bracket
Direct is our program
so that you can work directly
with our hardware supplies as well.
So if you wanna engage
on a particular problem
with IonQ or Regetti
or AQT or QuEra or IQM,
you can do it through that program.
So a lot of different ways to engage.
And then finally, just to wrap up,
we've got a lot of sessions
on quantum compute this week.
This is just a selection.
All of the sessions that
we've got on quantum computer
through the QR code there.
But I've just put a
selection on the slide here
so that if you wanna follow up on this
and go a little bit deeper,
please come to the
breakout session tomorrow
with JPMorgan Chase and
look at the applications
in the financial sector.
We've got some chalk talks
that go into hybrid compute,
into how we're using generative AI
to accelerate quantum
computing software development.
And then finally, a little bit more hubs,
which is what Eric was
talking about before
with those national
compute resource centers
and how we're integrating in with them.
So we're delighted that
you can make it along today
to this session to learn a little bit more
about what we're doing in
quantum technologies at AWS.
And we hope to see you
on Bracket in the future.
Thank you very much.